I'm grand Baker an NGO a school friend
here a group I won this I'm going to DC
Alma is located between two mountain
ranges the Boston to the north and the
watch thoughts of the south the arkansas
river cuts through the valley and Oh
Alan is this man capital of the world
so coach be president for a day
what should I ask for I don't know how
about a jump shot if I could be
president for a day out out all little
sisters and I would outlaw ask your turf
in baseball
my favorite sport is fernando de Soto
who came darken saw in the year 1541
searching for Gulf of Spanish Empire he
didn't find it but it could have found
something better had you stopped here
diamonds i'm here at murfreesboro
Arkansas North America's only diamond
mined and the eighth largest in the
world you can sit there diamonds all day
and whenever you find you get to keep
I'm actually standing right now on the
remains of an ancient volcano but all
that's left of it is a volcanic pipe
that runs beneath the surface and every
day it pushes fresh gems right to the
surface so let has to do it murphysboro
is looking around and pick one wrapped
it up
that's a little bit about me it's a
little bit of a Down see in DC
you